[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
taf tout à faire à plaisir c'est une
force tu as fait une force positive
constructive
porté par des femmes et des hommes qui
vont à la rencontre des plaisirs war
pour changer pour construire des idées
de changement pour la ville une force
centré sur une intelligence collective
et de partage il repose en tout cas sur
une politique des besoins auxquels on
adapte les moyens et il ya un fort
besoin un plaisir ce sont les liens les
liens entre les quartiers les habitants
les liens de circulation de mobilité
douce et on a une proposition
proposition de maison citoyenne que l'on
va retrouver dans tous ses quartiers et
tous les lieux de vie où il ya des
besoins
ces maisons citoyennes regroupe on fait
des permanences de services sociaux de
service public des activités culturelles
sportives remettre en place des
structures de jeunesse délai ouvrir les
stades les équipements sportifs ouvrir
les commissions municipales au plaisir
moi c'est à dire que vous savez
aujourd'hui les commissions municipales
regroupe des des élus et des services
donc on les use ou aux plaisirs oies et
des référents plaisir de chaque quartier
je pensais aux commissions municipales
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui comme celle
de la santé et du handicap
bien sûr un plan d'urgence il faut
lancer à plein de plein d'autres plans
d'urgence sur les mobilités douces et de
circulation et avoir une réflexion
globale d'une politique familiale qui
doit être absolument restructurer
notamment je pense aux tarifs municipaux
de la ville qui doit être changé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]